your belief is that the father the God
you have a personal relationship with
him in the father the father the father
seen in order for you to have salvation
you have to believe that I took an
innocent man he did nothing wrong to
anybody
I need his blood to forgive you I would
say look the way I understand mercy from
the Islamic perspective is the mercy
it's not like a final state that you aim
to reach there's two types of mercy
that's mercy that you can obtain in this
world and that's the final mercy that
you probably talking about which he will
obtain on their judgment or you know the
final day mercy it's not like something
that it's final with this more very
practice in Islam a process so you
continuously seek mercy by asking their
Almighty God Allah and and and so it's
mercy actually it's like a development
and it develops the character and also
it's an evolution the more you do it the
easier becomes for you you know to seek
mercy and it's it's but if you if you
want to get technical with it mercy is
in three parts so in order to obtain
mercy or willing to want mercy it means
that some some sound sometimes the sound
some time down the line you've you've
committed a sin right and in Islamic
what you do is that you first of all you
have to
reject the act of sinning on a
particular sin whatever you've done and
once you've done that you have to have
the determination not to go back even
though if you even though there might be
a possibility that you might go back but
at that point when you make that
decision you decides not to go back
again you believe that every single
human being yeah
is a sinner yeah I do believe that just
a leaf every single human being needs
mercy yeah
you will need have to say obtaining
mercy like like like I said you you
asked for it you asked for it you you
asked for it how are you guaranteed that
you receive this message is a guarantee
there is a what they also had these that
quite a narration sorry it's a narration
and a transmission that comes from the
Prophet it seems and there are very
beautiful ones in fact for example this
one where it says the Prophet says that
Allah says even if you were to come with
sins as high as the sky or like as in I
would still forgive you
so mercy is not a door that is closed
ever until you you enter the grave so
that's why I was saying it's a process
you keep doing it so but when you ask
yeah in Islam when you ask God for
something yeah do you have a guaranteed
proof that you you're gonna receive what
you've asked yeah
no ago it was nothing so the thing is
it's now when you mean guaranteed yeah
we these we are told you could peace
yeah but how could this is are not
what's going to lead us to paradise okay
because from the get-go we are indebted
to God from the day that were born yeah
we are indebted to God hi okay because
nothing that we can do could be enough
for for us to say you know what God will
be paid you back for what you've done
for us because there is a hadith and
narration the same of the Prophet peace
be upon him he told us that on the day
of judgement a man will come and he will
say to God Almighty I would like to
enter paradise with my good teacher I do
not I do not want to enter paradise with
your mercy I trust my food is that good
enough okay God says okay no problem I
want to sit instead enter that with my
mercy
why you wanna enter paradise will
complete so what he did is he took that
man's I put it on the scales but one of
the cookies that he did and the I await
who does good deeds okay so what we
learn from that is the following is that
and and I just finish off
he said God Almighty said well now you
destined to hell because I'm being
judged this is my justice my justice
means that's the I that you have your
good days if we did it journey will
never repay me back for the either I'm
giving you the blessing and the mercy of
the eye so when he was when he's when
God said to him go to hell he said but
please i want to enter paradise with
your mercy because he understood that
will justice he's indebted
so that's the reason why we as human
beings from the get-go we there is no
how do you how do you obtain mercy into
shamp you have to believe that Jesus
died for the sins I am the way I am the
life I am the truth now nobody comes to
the Father except through me
I would ask the simple question system
tell me which is more merciful in Islam
God tells us that if you sin and he
sends it to reach the mountains in the
skies I will forgive every sin
one of them unload as long as you don't
associate partners with me
no blood sacrifice no innocent person
has to die Christianity the only way I
will forgive the sins is that I need
blood sacrifice of an innocent man
talking about mercy can you kindly tell
me which one seems more merciful to you
and why Jesus Christ his whole being was
to be born and to die that was his
purpose for my sins because for God so
loved the world that He gave His one and
only begotten Son yeah the whosoever
shall believe that's everybody anyone
white black Indian Chinese do anybody
yeah it is the door is open to anyone
yeah it's whoever wants him now okay
there's no discrimination yeah
everybody's invited
yeah you either accept him now while
you're walking or you pay the
consequences later okay so which one for
why I said Christianity the god of
Christianity requires do not sacrifice
that's key element in Islam nobody needs
to die there is no blood sacrifice
needed all you have to do is ask for
repentance and you forgive this why you
don't have that's why you don't have a
guarantee that you can I can't die for
my truth me I can offer up myself to die
not to go and kill other people in the
name of Jesus
yeah understand what I'm saying me I
can't die from me myself yes
for the truth that I believe in that
Jesus Christ is life he's awake he the
truth unaccounted to God without him yes
Jesus Christ is a guarantee and without
Jesus Christ yes without Jesus Christ I
have no guarantee okay so once in
sisters forgive me maybe you have an
insurance if it's true I'm saying sister
look I repeat again the the God of Islam
says no blood is needed for me
no innocent person needs to die for me
you sin Europe
I know where you're going
yeah but you didn't ask my question when
you're in your household if your father
gives you an instruction yes and you
disobey does it just say oh my son it's
okay I'm not going to punish you you've
been a well done you've done baby
but does it give you a puddin is there
know maybe if you can forgive you
forgive me so you grow up you grow up
with that in a discipline then no not
really if I'm if I'm a god from god this
princess for me now okay so okay okay
sorry listen to me so this is no no no
listen to me okay
listen to me God is everyone's God as a
creator yes but he's only a father to
those who choose him to be okay I'm
seeing a difference I understand you're
talking of a God the Creator I took of
God the Father
okay sister one seems okay you have good
the father how can my father can
corrects me my father nope no problem
same with our stimulus but what I'm
saying is look please hear me out your
belief is that the father the God you
have a personal relationship with
another father the father's the father
saying in order for you to have
salvation you have to believe that I
took an innocent man he did nothing
wrong to anybody
I need his blood to forgive you because
you came today an awesome immersion
Lamia in Islam God doesn't say to me Ali
I need you to believe that I require a
blood sacrifice and I'm going to kill
innocent man what's this to me
Ali oh you have to do is say there's
preconditions to repentance you have
stopped the sin you hate the sin and you
don't go back to the same okay that is
it that means you believe that from this
so what you're saying to me is no what
you're saying to me is when you sing
today Father forgive me I said forgive
me that means for the rest of your life
you've never
again no I can't I'll return back to
repentance hold on hold on so which
means are gonna be you're gonna be
repenting for the rest of your life yes
yes yes okay so blood no yes so my God
knows I'm a sinner
yes and I accept that I'm a sinner yes
my punishment is death my punishment is
hell
that's not mercy so my god his life for
me so go in my place listen listen
he took my punishment than I deserve yes
good night my god died for me in my
place so before you talk about sacrifice
he did not take an innocent man Jesus
forgive me I'm asking a simple question
in Islam nobody has to die no he came
here today and he said I want to know
why what does Mercy mean you came in us
today
why is mercy in Islam mercy in Islam is
that no blood is required nobody needs
to die
okay sister if somebody goes and kill
for example Lord's Resistance Army in
the Central Africa they kill Muslims not
only do they kill them they burn them
and eat them in the name of Christ
Rhodri tsunami okay are you in the fight
where the Bible doesn't teach yes it
does no the first is no first time you
chapter 15 verse 2 to 3 it says go to
their Malachi's kill men women children
babies and donkeys no way in the quran
does it say such thing thank you because
there is sinful people there was a
sinful nation so you're justifying the
killing of babies in churches and
donkeys are you justifying them if they
won't accept God's Way who are you man
to question God